via BP baby don't say that
do you hear what my girlfriend just said
well Tyrone is here you could be a DP
I'm talking about a cinematographer
director of photography [ __ ] pervert
I really didn't know what you were done
Oh
Varys the looker buying clothes to ask
him after we were done
hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Tyrone
Magnus Tyrone Magnus is here sitting
next to me in the flesh surprisingly
we're around the same height yes we are
it's pretty embarrassing for Tyrone
Tyrone is afraid of Ryan now because you
found is an extraordinary fighter
I can fight that's right if a homosexual
tastes for black men with muscular butts
so and you know I've seen your bulge
that I met you in person
yeah but suck little Thai roses or
should I say major Tyrone afraid of
being raped but Veronica's here in the
background so I'll show Rochelle rape
you - I don't know never make rape jokes
but it's a special video today is teeny
tiny she's actually smaller than I
thought guys like you could put her in
your little pocket but her breasts still
look great like despite her skinniness
she still has great Bresson see those
Ryan has not got well we will in
February sis you a point for mm-hmm
you guys stop telling people when I'm
dreaming about her doing I want to share
her body with the world I want to share
your body with the world I love you you
know I don't you you you deserve it
doesn't matter you know what you can
become a DP if you want no all right
guys honest trailers fantastic for 2015
version I saw this movie thought it
sucked Tyrone said he didn't like it you
can barely even remember right now so
we're gonna have honest trailers refresh
us about the hatred can I give you a few
tips on reactions oh sure I mean I
figure you could really use my help you
only have like 250,000 more subs in it
be honest don't talk over too much when
other people are talking in the video
and um no just you know like just show
how you feel just let it out
will you express yourself yeah yeah like
now is going on I think you would really
help your channel if you learn how to do
that
I'm gonna take the advice to this big
city Los Angeles movie guy cuz he'll I
don't know what I'm talking about let's
talk about this movie are suck more than
San Francisco homosexual alright sir
okay
how'd you successfully make me feel
uncomfortable I don't know how to just
happened
from the director of Quantico and a
fantastic version of this movie you'll
probably never see and the studio that
already brought you two ridiculously
campy fantastic four movies comes a
reboot that's completely different yet
somehow still just as bad fan four stick
it's been famous since the last good
Fantastic Four movie now Fox must crank
out another one or lose the rights to a
studio that would do a much better job
so prepare for the obligatory trotting
out of Marvel's first family like you've
never seen them before
Moody awkward and really really low
energy and now here sunny we're mean for
people who are never referred to as mr.
fantastic the thing Invisible Woman the
Human Torch and a fool it's true I know
there's read the genius who can bend his
body into new and exciting ethnicities a
big hearted rock monster whose
superpower is not having genitals
underused actress in a terrible way
who's left behind to make the guys
uniforms I'm making the environment
suits and Johnny a street racing brat
cliche with the power to ignite internet
comment sections for being a black guy
for Institute where kids create
billion-dollar inventions powerful
enough to destroy the world in exchange
for Pat's on the back
we all deserve an enormous pat on the
back and wonder how these child geniuses
also managed to be total idiots as they
get wrong recruit reads unqualified
childhood friend who gave them a
screwdriver one time teleport to Mordor
take some selfies this one is definitely
going on Instagram and immediately stick
their hands and alien goofs
don't touch the goofs salient planet
rule number one tremble in anticipation
for the return of one of Marvel's
greatest super villains
Doctor Doom then shake your head in
disappointment when you're stuck with
the super-powered sex doll instead hop
complete with vague abilities
big motivations and fake Ghostbusters
references ariannol Dana only Zuul
there is no Victor who dr. tunes the
movie just when things start to get
interesting to deliver a ridiculous
finale where a villain who can literally
do anything with just his mind loses two
for and F teenagers whose best strategy
is to punch him in the face haha so get
ready for a superhero film that's a
shame to admit it's a superhero film
they're not powers they're aggressively
abnormal physical conditions be drink
some of Hollywood's hottest young actors
totally phoning it in we're a team now
and there's four of us so we should come
up with a name for it
clumsy references to the comic books
after doom over here hey what's up and
bizarre shifts in time that seem to mark
exactly when the studio took over from
the director who is to blame for the
overwhelmingly negative reviews for
Fantastic Four well director Josh Trank
is saying not in currently sitting at a
nine percent with critics on Rotten
Tomatoes geez what a mess the movie
about making this movie would be so much
better than this movie starring were you
stretching or were you dragging a wasted
house of cards actor a chocolate snowman
Michael be glad you don't have to do any
more of these another wasted house of
cards actor
and questios to me fantastic for strike
three man you know it's bad when Stanley
won't even make a cameo be sure it has
trailer that's right hey screen junkies
as a Thanksgiving thank you to all our
fans we are unlocking every show on
screen junkies plus this weekend
starting at midnight on Wednesday
through Sunday that's right
you can gobble up every new show dude I
would love to get on screen junkies
would love to get on screen Jacques de
Sevilla they're pretty cool that's one
of my Jan I'm a junkie
you know like Tyrone saw so prepare for
this video I had to take home on a
heroin so much heroin and tell you
really took the edge off as really took
the edge off hippler - and he's an
enabler
every friend needs an enabler this so is
his girlfriend
so my girlfriend's an enabler yeah she's
a coke act yes um okay you're not a coke
addict I'm sorry okay I'm sorry she's
not a coke addict I'm sorry I said Jesus
Christ loves us both a couple things I
pointed out that I sort of forgot about
none of them are ever referred to by
their superhero names that's a big no-no
for me even Batman Begins he has that
scene where he does say I'm Batman when
he picks the guy out of the car that's a
more realistic version and stuff so some
people might argue that this Fantastic
Four was like well it's a more realistic
take so they really call themselves
goofy nicknames right but I'm like come
on now you need to do that yeah they do
that in common man still - they didn't
call in Superman except you Harry at one
time he heard at one time yeah so yeah I
thought it worked how they used it like
that and I Marilla Michael B Jordan hey
Tyrone from a black man's perspective
yes what was it like to deep hear about
Michael B Jordan becoming the Human
Torch and all the outcry about it well
[ __ ] man I was taught all the
[ __ ] crackers more than all the
goddamn superheroes was in it so it's
about time my brother got shot at you
know I'm saying yeah man I know what you
talking about I know what you talked
about dawg damn it this is how I talk to
Tyrone off camera
Roger passed a weed [ __ ] pass the wean
and word and n-word she's really
surprised to see this side of you today
yeah put on different things doom was
probably the most disappointing part of
the film I remember that he was shoehorn
in it at the last second it was such a
disappointing finale and I didn't even
notice that's how they took him down was
just punch him in the face now the
design thing I'm the you that win ofin
when the third act came right were you
like oh we're in the third act like I
did were other movie reviews yeah like
yo like what yeah yeah no it was seein
already the way it was structured not
because it was a short movie but the way
it was all structured it was like no
consistency and it wasn't clear so when
we got to the finale it was like oh
we're in the finale this movie's ending
yes we're in the final fight yeah but he
just became do yeah right I couldn't
wait to get out it was the worst part
about that film to me is that it's
boring like it's a boring film you know
Terminator Genisys was not a really good
film but it was entertaining to me you
know yeah I there I had a good time
yeah I had a good time with it like I'm
not gonna say it's like the a good film
or a great film but I'm like it's still
fun and I was entertained but with
Fantastic Four this film I thought was
so dull and so boring there's like no
life it's not even bad fun it's just
boring and bad you know we're in bed not
fun you can at least be entertaining
it'll probably be one of those movies
that people watch that like Watson B
movies yeah you know that's was [ __ ] but
even B movies can be a lot more fun in
this [ __ ] what's his name I keep
forgetting his name from schmoes know
that madman gave Fantastic Four like
three out of five snows Oh what I gotta
ask you something right now you were
doing a couple of segments with the
schmoes now and you can't remember one
of their names right now I
no one reason I don't know what it is
about him he reminds me something about
his demeanor what he is how he is how he
acts reminds me of Ben Affleck I don't
know what it is but it's that one
Kristian harloff yes you know some
people just looked at it as a sci-fi
flick rather than a superhero flick and
I think that was what allowed them to
maybe give it a different review no but
yes if you take that perspective it
might change it when I was watching it
like the first half of that movie I
honestly thought was like okay this is
interesting this is a science fiction
picture this isn't necessarily a comic
book movie it's more of a sci-fi pic but
even as a science fiction film I think
it greatly fails like even if you just
look it as a sci-fi film the way
everything goes I'm like I can only
imagine how much of a letdown this was
for fans of the comics I don't read the
comics for Fantastic Four and I still
thought the whole thing sucked you know
so please release a director's cut oh
yeah he deserved he needs one even
though the kicked on earth as his cut
for Superman to please release that for
this and Michael B Jordan man [ __ ] like
I'm watching a you're right hey after
watching create a beat like this guy
deserves an Oscar it's so sad to be like
oh yeah he was once in this I thinking
like you for thinking who the kid good
thing I got yeah good thing he was
successful yeah you know like the East
acosta react astok for and I would call
this the fantastic foursome can you
imagine the four of us you me Gator
Hakkasan I mean [ __ ] would be five but
you know Gator and [ __ ] count as one
foursome with fantastical we mean what
kind of force them the train that we
create you go first I go second third or
no we're talking we're talking about a
train circle-jerk train or Circle Jerks
we're all in a circle and jerking I'm
talking about penetration train
Oh No circle jerk what are you [ __ ]
come on rounder man up nunu
gotta go all the way out too many dicks
in that party my party is only one day I
allow two at a max hey Veronica
hahaha hi Roger
I can say whatever I want now and she
won't know what I'm saying I didn't say
anything I don't think I could ever do
it threesome anyway cuz we're all swords
we cross swords it would be a magical
experience there would be like some
laser being that light shoots up that
leads us into another dimension we go
for it yeah there hope that if we have a
threesome we cross swords you believe
this guy Roger imagine that switch yeah
maybe you don't need to be there for
them
I understand anyway guys listen thanks
for tuning into the channel if you're
new to it subscribe today become a
reject what I called him unfortunately
Magne sites are way cooler rejects you
[ __ ] yeah and Tyrone he has a channel
obviously if you've heard of me chances
are you've heard of Tyrone Magnus and
way more of you have let's face it its
fanbase is significantly larger it's
like comparing our penises like his has
it's about the same yeah that flowed out
just perfectly like it like if he
whipped it out it would extend past the
screen Framus it would fade the black
mane to black let's end the video there
people